jump into this first story and talk
about the end of the world how about
that we have this from The Intercept
truth cops that's the headline it's
amazing leaked documents outline
Homeland Securities plans to police
disinformation I'm kind of surprised
they put it that lightly let me show you
this Twitter thread from Lee Fang one of
the writers on this article he says docs
show Facebook and Twitter closely
collaborating with the Department of
Homeland Security and FBI 2 police
disinfo plans to expand the censorship
on topics like withdrawal from
Afghanistan origins of covid info that
undermines trust in financial
institutions FBI agent Laura demlow was
in communication with Facebook that led
to the suppression of the hunter Biden
laptop story in 2020 over the false
allegation that it was disinformation
this year she met with Twitter DHS to
stress quote we need a media
infrastructure that is held accountable
check this out Facebook and Twitter
created a special created special
portals for government to rapidly
request takedowns of content the portal
along with the NGO Partners used to
censor a wide range of content including
obvious parity accounts and content
disagreeing with government pandemic
policy that right there the government
doesn't like that you're dissenting was
colluding with Communications platforms
private collusion literal conspiracy to
silence you for your dissent
check this out there's text messages
right here the emails and documents show
close collaboration between DHS and
private sector Twitter's Vijaya got a
fired by Elon Musk last week met monthly
with DHS to discuss censorship plans
Microsoft exec texted DHS quote
platforms have to get comfortable with
government incredible
he says how does DHS justify its
evolving Mission from countering foreign
Terror groups to policing domestic
disinfo on social media leaked planning
docs show the agency argues false
information is a source of
radicalization and violence and of
course I really want you to see this
this right here is the Facebook URL for
the Facebook what is the portal is for
onboarded partner requests pertaining to
content issues on Facebook and Instagram
if you're an onboarded partner please
put in your request through this portal
still live the Facebook link for the
government to go and and tell Facebook
what to take down is still available
right now
this CR this is crazy this report's
actually ridiculously long hours reading
through it it's massive they mentioned
that they were policing information and
say like racial Justice for what reason
what justification would the government
have to do anything like this outright
it's subverting our elections especially
now they're saying it's ongoing and
Twitter Executives Facebook Microsoft
were meeting with the DHS to police what
they deem is dis disinformation
misinformation and Mal information and
uh to me this is far beyond that this is
a criminal conspiracy this is the
government colluding with big Tech
social media in order to make sure that
they have all the power all the
influence and anyone daring to just
question them not just about you know
racial justice issues as you mentioned
here but but the topics here that they
specifically decided to intervene on
make them look bad it was also
Afghanistan it was also the origin of
covet it was also a product that of
course they were working in colluding to
make a lot of people take and and when
you look at those issues what are those
issues have in common especially
Afghanistan they clearly show something
that the government got wrong they
clearly LED people down a wrong pathway
they clearly screwed the people of
Afghanistan over they they clearly
screwed all the soldiers there but they
wanted to control the narrative so they
could still look like they did something
good when they obviously did something
horrible and when you're doing that when
you when you're when you're creating
god-like power and authority to silence
people to censor people and to control
narratives we're talking about huge
amounts of power that that is almost
virtually impossible to to hold anyone
accountable to
I'm trying to elevate my perception to
the level of global governance like if
if I was in control of American Military
and and there's like a world because
like for me I'm an American citizen
American politics and and the
Constitution that's key if you violate
the constitution you're messing up but
then you elevate to the next level of
like I'm now in control of the military
and they in turn Japanese people during
World War II though they will violate
the constitution in times of great
stress to make sure that we all survive
I'm I I need this this is going to be
settling in I mean I had a feeling that
they've been doing this since you know
2012 2013 but it's just but I don't know
if it has to happen yeah I've been
screaming about this this has been
happening for years and everyone's like
you know you can't really prove it it's
not happening because when you look at
all the censorship efforts that they
were they were doing throughout the
years it all made sense that this was
organized not for the benefit of big
Tech social media but for the benefit of
the people in charge in power and now we
have the documents now it's proven sorry
I cut you off no absolutely I mean it's
to me it's I I feel sorry for those who
still believe we have a truly private
sector because really this is the
government they're Outsourcing you know
their dirty work to these giant Tech
corporations and you know we saw it
during covid you know we we saw it I
think it really started during the 2016
elections you know because Trump I mean
Trump won in large part in my opinion
due to his influence on social media he
was able to
um you know go around the the corporate
Legacy Media you know go around that
distorting prism of their influence and
go directly to the people and they kind
of had this Rubicon this never again
moment we're not gonna let this happen
again you know we can't let these
America First populist types go around
our you know geek keeping mechanism and
go straight to the voters and so that's
where it started in my opinion I'm sure
it happened before that but wait 2016
was kind of the collective never again
moment and I think it was accelerated
through Trump's Administration
um you know they they they took it
exponentially uh you know higher during
Cova during 2020 and it's just it's
really sad because there's so many
politicians and and people in the GOP
you know our leaders who are supposed to
be representing us at the highest level
who are still fighting the same battle
they were they were pretending to fight
back in the 80s you know it was a you
know a give and take on corporate tax
rates and you know we're the We're the
Party of small government and we're the
party of you know uh freedom of
Enterprise and and that that that battle
has been lost and so now we're seeing
this terrifying Union of big government
tyranny and outsourced to these big Tech
corporations and nothing can be more
um you know subversive to Liberty and
you know until we recognize that until
we as a people and we as a you know
Republican party those on the right
until we just come to grips with that
new reality we're never going to be able
to even you know much less defeat it
even fight back against it take a look
at this in the story
Trump signed uh Trump signed it they say
that the the stepped up counter
disinformation effort began in 2018
following high-profile hacking incidents
of U.S firms when Congress passed and
president Donald Trump signed the cyber
security and infrastructure Security
Agency act forming a new wing of DHS
wow Trump trump probably he said hey it
sounds like a good idea to me I wonder
if you read it probably not probably not
he probably had some advisor just be
like this is good it's going to protect
our infrastructure and it was like make
sense to me and he signed off on it
little did he know that all of a sudden
now damning information that was bad
about say Joe Biden's family would be
suppressed because the FBI was going to
Facebook and being like look out for
this yes and not only that but but this
is specifically referencing this story
by The Intercept and these leaked
documents are specifically mentioning
the the hunter Biden story which they
even named the FBI agent in this story
that went to Facebook and said hey this
is disinformation you got to take this
down when the FBI knew that they were
lying through their teeth after their
interview with Tony bobolinski they knew
that the hunter Biden story was legit it
wasn't Russian disinformation but but
Trump signed into law what essentially
was a major component and part of him
getting kicked out of office which is
absolutely crazy uh and not only that
but but a lot of the nonsense that the
American people had to go through within
the last two and a half to three years
when it came to covid the lockdowns
small businesses being shut down they
were only able to get away with it
because they dominated the conversation
anyone speaking out against them would
be censored would be kicked offline
doctors would be kicked out of medical
boards would have their licenses taken
away for even questioning what was going
on here and now we're finding out that
was that was what the doj and the FBI
were making sure was happening because
now we're finding out that they were at
the head of making a lot of these
decisions pushing for censorship pushing
for disinformation not in in an alleged
fight against fighting it but in reality
they were really pushing it no no you
said were they are did you say that the
portal is still active on Facebook right
now they specifically went to Facebook
and asked them to censor specifically
the hunter Biden story okay then Mark
Zuckerberg lied to Joe Rogan yeah he
said yes look they were not specifically
or he didn't know look at this there is
a Facebook portal where they can go and
specifically say take this down now hold
on to be specific and to be very careful
Mark Zuckerberg may be the one time that
the FBI didn't have have to go through
this portal and they were talking a mark
on the phone maybe he was referring to
some very specific moment and that's how
it went down you're not going to
convince me when Facebook has an active
portal for government takedown requests
that they went to Mark and said there
may be a story we can't tell you which
one though and then Mark Witt better
take down this Hunter button laptop
story don't buy it not when they when
Facebook built them a portal to
specifically request takedowns yeah and
when you look at the story and
specifically the tweets they they
mentioned an FBI agent Laura Delma I I
uh delmo low demo and specifically
referencing the hunter Biden story to
the FBI to to Facebook right so so
they're mentioning it from all these
leaked documents it's more in our face
more than ever and I'm sure the story is
well sourced and I'm sure there are some
Within These institutions who are you
know on our side but you know to my to
to my mind I'm wondering where the where
is the right wing resistance inside
these institutions
and it's kind of like the dog that
didn't bark we're not seeing the kind of
organize resistance to the bite
Administration that we saw from these
institutions in permanent DC as during
the Trump Administration so that tells
me these these institutions they're
they're they're they're beyond being
salvaged they're not reformable and I
just don't I don't hear enough from
people who are in politics on our side
on on the right kind of the old right as
I say who truly grasped that who say
like you know there's no there's no
nipping around the edges of the FBI
there's no nipping around the edges of
the doj there's no nipping around the
edges of these of DHS because they are
they are in cahoots with with permanent
Washington with the left-wing media with
big Tech you know and until we
understand the power of that Union we
can't defeat it yeah you got to build
systems that are indiscernible that are
like um decentralized that are mesh
networks that aren't relying on
centralized services that run under the
radar because I don't think you mean
compete with global government military
force you mean like the lava bit uh
email servers Ian that's specifically
we're started that Edward Snowden was
using where the NSA came to and gave
them an official national security
letter saying shut up give us all your
information or you're going to jail the
lava bit story I actually interviewed
the founder a few years ago ladar
Levinson uh absolutely stood up to some
crazy Insanity when it came to the
federal government coming after him
trying to of course spy on
whistleblowers and he leaked that story
and he actually safeguarded a lot of
very important uh you know data and
information this is lava bit is an open
source encrypted Webmail service founded
in 2004 and it was 2013 the government
ordered it to turn over its SSL private
keys so that then there yeah I think the
service should not be holding on to the
private Keys those should be the only
the sender and receiver should have
those keys that's a big part of it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to Tim cast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there